it's been a minute since flip or flop
was on the air what did it feel like to
take that break did you need it you know
it's kind of funny I didn't realize how
long the break was until you just told
me so you know what life goes so fast
and I've been doing the show so long
that it feels great to be back on TV you
know so season 8 is 18 episodes and we
have one episode down that was last week
so we have 17 more to go 17 where to go
yeah
well it's really here's what I love you
you guys might be one of the first if
not the first couple to ever lean into
hey we're exes and we're doing this show
together the show we used to do together
we're now still doing together and the
promos have fun with it what's it been
like for you to film with Christina you
know like like anything let's just be
honest at the beginning of the
separation it was like pulling teeth it
was very very difficult and as you know
time heals things and as time has gone
on it's gotten easier and easier and
today things are great the on-screen
chemistry is great and we get along well
and we get there we do our job and I
think we do a pretty good job well I
watched the show for years and you guys
you've always had kind of a bit of like
a teasing banter you disagree on things
so does it almost work we don't see eye
to eye on everything clearly so yeah and
I think it makes it an interesting show
yeah you know I think we're both
opinionated and we both have certain
needs and wants and we have ideas of
what we want to do two houses and
there's some of the changes you'll see
as I put my foot down a lot more now
because I'm allowed to because I can no
these are great I do you are you a
little bit more like you know what I
don't have to worry about things at home
now so I really can't say my piece yeah
to be honest yeah hundred percent yeah
did you guys talk about what it would be
like I mean I would imagine you had to
have conversations of do we want to
continue the show now that we're split
up and what were those conversations
like you know those are what I mean
there were probably thousands of
conversations with many different people
whether we were going to continue or not
because it was a very big decision going
through a very tough time in our lives
but at the end of the day we have kids
we have careers we work really hard to
get to where we are and you know it's
our job and we love what we do and the
fans enjoy watching the show and you
know
we have to show a good good parenting
for our children so we continued with
the show and very happy we did why are
you happy you did um you know what
because life is all about experiences
and it's it's a great thing to say that
season 8 of flipper flop is on the air
you know it takes a lot of hard work to
make it happen and it was worth it
because to see the results and just to
share our lives with the world it's
really exciting I would imagine that
like you said I mean in the beginning
the tension is probably there more how
would you describe the growth that you
guys have been through what was key to
getting where you are now you know it's
just one of those things time heals a
lot of things and we understand that it
is a job and we're all professional and
when we show up to set when we're there
to film we want to make a great show and
we're both on the same page when it
comes to that I would imagine that you
didn't want to throw away everything
you've worked for exactly you know like
I've worked so hard my entire life and
you know there's a decision you have to
make sometimes do you throw away
everything you've worked for for the
last 20 years because of your emotions
or do you suck it up deal with the
emotions and keep doing what you're
doing so I made the decision to keep
doing what I was doing yeah and I would
also imagine that's something where like
you were just saying you got to feel
good about the example that's setting
for your kids yeah it's very important
that our kids know that you know even
though we're not together I mean we're
still in a sense of family you know what
was it like when you first saw the
promos because the promos are funny
they're like you know what's it like
working with your ex yeah they are kind
of they are kind of buddy I it made me
laugh so I'm assuming everybody else
watching it laughed right yeah and I
think that's one of the exciting things
about the show people want to know what
is next because we aren't married I mean
she has remarried and she's having a
baby so things have changed quite a bit
in our lives so I think the viewers have
an opportunity to see those changes yeah
you know I I was just with her I
interviewed her and I said what's that
conversation like you guys worked
together so closely for you to tell tark
that you're expecting another baby and
she said no I'd give him a call and I
gave him a heads-up how did you react to
hearing about all that it was an
unexpected call okay hose up it was a
surprise yeah it was right did I okay so
you just didn't know that she was gonna
head that way I had no idea no but no
I'm happy with them you know what
they're like
her and her husband ant they live a
block away he's honestly seems like a
super nice guy my kids like him so I'm
happy for a block away yeah that's
impressed you guys are like you're like
Gweneth Paltrow consciously uncoupling
here this is impressive I don't know
much about what she's doing but it
sounds like we do similar things well I
would imagine a block away is helpful
for the kids you know I mean they're
close and it is that important for you
guys it's very important it makes life a
lot easier you know and it's just nice
knowing that a night when I'm sleeping
if they're with her I know that they're
close to me yeah so I've seen a couple
clips from the new season you know we
got things like again you guys are
leaning into your you're competing on
your choices for for tile designs
she's pranking you with not bringing you
the right pulls for a cabinet are things
more competitive than ever between you
two I would say so I would say yeah like
we just we're having fun again and
that's what's that's what's important
you know for a while there filming
wasn't fun anymore and now it's fun
again and you can see that when you
watch the show how did you get through
it when it wasn't fun anymore because
filming such a big part of your life you
know like I said you know life's tough
and I just had to suck it up and it was
a job and it was very difficult to do
but I'm glad I pulled it off I won't ask
it because look fans feel very connected
to you and I think they're gonna look at
you guys and think they got through this
and it'll give them inspiration when you
were thinking god this is a job I got to
suck it up what kind of got you through
that emotionally did you lean on friends
did you tell yourself I got to do this
for my kids what was that um for me like
my biggest thing was always thinking
about my kids and what's best for them
and what's important for them and when I
make any decision today the first
thought is is this good for my kids yeah
yeah and if they've been on set with you
guys a lot we see them in the season
yeah you'll see you on the season and
then they're filming with me on my new
shows and it's just really exciting and
it's amazing how big my daughters
getting she's gonna be nine my son's
gonna be four I remember when we shot
the home video Christina was five months
pregnant and Taylor was actually in her
belly like we've been doing this that
long that's crazy I mean do you and
Christina just kind of share this
understanding now of hey we've got to
support each other in our next chapters
like have you met an
you guys you know is it is everything
cool of course you know we all go to
soccer games we all sit together on the
sidelines I'm the crazy dad riding and
screaming you know normal stuff well I
want to ask you about the next phases of
your life you just mentioned your new
shows and also you are apparently dating
somebody new yes I am a lovely lady
sitting over there while she's sitting
right here he's sitting right over there
yes so I was very lucky to have met the
lovely Heather ray and she's on the
amazing TV show selling Sunset and I
must say she's brilliant she's loving
she's caring she's supportive and I just
adore her and I'm having a great time
and I'm saying words I never thought I
would say again she's my girlfriend and
I'm very excited about what the future
holds for us well why did you think
you'd never say those words again you
know I just went through some pretty
traumatic things in my life and I was
honestly I was very happy and
comfortable on my own and I didn't
realize what I was missing until I found
what I was missing
so here we are okay I gotta tell you she
just applauded the things that you said
she's just so adorable yeah okay you're
smiling right now your wife is real
smile probably blushing - sorry world
good I introduced her to my kids last
night for the first time my mom my dad
my mom's husband my sister so so we're
doing it yeah yeah yeah very excited
well I mean like you said she's she's in
a similar industry I would imagine that
binds you guys what else is it that's
making you smile ear to ear about this
lady she just makes me feel really good
and happy you know it's like I was sad
for a very long time I was alone for a
very long time
and I feel like she's like really
brought me back to life which is very
very fun to say yeah yeah well I
interviewed you a couple years ago and I
do have to tell you you you have a very
different energy right now than you did
changed a little bit how was it having
to meet the kids no it was actually fun
they had a great time my daughter of
course fell in love with her because
Heather's just amazing and my son you
know he's 3 years old he's just running
around like a crazy man but it was a
great night we had a lot of fun okay
yeah well and you know you live a block
from Christina this
soccer games did you tell her hey
Heather's gonna meet the kids like have
you talked to her about Heather
we actually no I haven't talked to her
about Heather yet so that's probably a
talk I should probably have pretty soon
like maybe today considering like I'm
talking about it on TV now she'll
probably find out I think right yeah
yeah I think you should give her yeah
I'll give her a call but no like like
life's good like I'm super excited like
me now they're having a great time yeah
a flip or flop season they were just
came back on the air last week
yeah a new episode tonight 9:00 p.m.
Tarts flip side you know about that one
yes no top words we're gonna get it I
mean I just told him going through your
Instagram you got a podcast you got on
your show I mean is this also kind of
rejuvenating you all this work they're
doing yes I am more motivated than I've
ever been in my life and I love I love
just saying that I'm just getting
started because I really feel like I'm
just getting started when you say you're
just getting started what do you want to
accomplish from here what's on the
bucket list you know I just want to
continue to do what I'm doing at a much
higher level and I just want to continue
to live a great life and just be happy
and surround myself by great people and
just really build a really positive TV
career and business career of course
when you say that you're in such a
different place now how would you
describe the guy of a couple years ago
what place was he in um you know I was a
guy that lost everything you know I hit
rock bottom
you know I I was at the lowest lowest
lowest point of my life to the point
where I can barely get out of bed and
today I hop out of bed mostly cuz I have
a very obnoxious tomorrow I'm really
happy did you think you could get to
this place no what was really the key
hard work it's like anything in life I
just put a lot of work into myself and
really focus on trying to become the
person that I've always wanted to be and
that lady seems like she's helps a
little bit too okay well if you guys are
in the same industry could we see a show
with the two of you together you know
what you never know what can happen in
this crazy reality TV world is something
in the works no nothing is in the works
but you never know I mean you it would
be like your sixth seventh eighth ninth
project so I think you just go just do
it well what is it like though for you I
mean we're sitting here we're doing an
interview now about your new
relationship what's it like for you to
kind of start dating again in the
spotlight we see the paparazzi get
photos of you that kind of thing how's
that well this is the first time in
three-and-a-half years so this is the
first time I am like officially dating
in this I have a real girlfriend you
know it's like it's new it's fun it's
exciting it's exciting so you're you're
you're like we're posting about it I'm
in take your photos I don't care I'm
happy that's it and we like literally
just started posting yesterday so yeah
we're doing it we're right on the door
it's happening okay I was like you know
I guess I'm going on TV and I'm telling
the world about it we should probably
you know start posting about got it
these are discussions you have to add
today it's weird I mean I have them too
you're like wait when are we are we
gonna go it needs to be Facebook now
it's like are we Instagram official
reposting do you talk about these things
I see status no I know idea
girlfriend I think so tell me a little
bit about the spin-off show so flip or
flop obviously the main one and then
tark's flip side okay is a digital
series which is on HGTV calm and it kind
of shows people how I live outside of
being the house liver guy so I had a
really fun time doing it like they
roasted me we did an episode where I was
like you know mean tweets we did
shooting with the kids we had so much
fun filming with the kids and you know
we talked about my personal life and
that my cancer struggles and I think the
torx flipside the digital series it came
out great and it's probably my favorite
project I've done for many different
reasons
that's awesome yeah by the way with your
health I mean are you is how is
everything cuz it's been how many years
since that scare it's been six years and
everything's going really really well so
everything's looking good and I feel
like I'm in the best shape of my life
best health in my life and I feel good
okay so torch it yeah and the torch
flipside is digital but the actual
series series which will air on HGTV
next year is called flipping 101 I'm
Tarek el Moussa where I come in and I
help Ricky flippers you know buy fix and
flip houses and to be honest with you
when I was first approached for the show
I was thinking well it's gonna be boring
I'm just gonna stand there show people
what to do and they're gonna do it
because I've done close to 500 houses
totally wrong so I did the pilot and I
was like you have to do ABCD and I come
back to the house and they did
Q Y Z are like make no sense like they
didn't listen to anything I said like
I'm like what made you do that like boy
we thought that would be better like
house
have you done well one okay but they're
like I've seen a lot of shows like flip
or flop okay you're like well I've done
a lot show so if that might be the key
difference there maybe you should have
listened to me will we see the kids get
into mom and dad's world do they want to
be flippers like like you and Christina
oh yeah already talks about how she's
gonna be my boss one day of course love
it
but she loves real-estate loves houses
loves designing yeah we filmed together
last week and she actually helped me
design a house and it was like my
favorite scene of everything that has to
be kind of emotional as dad to be
thinking here's my little girl doing the
thing I love to do and she's loving it
yeah so much fun oh I love that I I feel
like there's nothing there's nothing
that can get to dad like a little girl
like yeah she owns me yeah like Target
would you ever have more kids you know
what you never know you never know where
you're gonna be you know three years
five years ten years from now yeah so
right today like I couldn't really
imagine that but who knows yeah how are
the kids reacting to having another
sibling have you talked to them about it
at all oh they're very excited I think
they are very excited there's there's a
lot of I love how much love there is in
their lives right now in yours this is
this is really great they they really do
have a lot of support from me and my
family Christina and her family they are
very loved and they know they're very
loved which is very important for them
to you know live a great life yeah
really I'm really sitting you're
thinking I'm really thinking back to
that interview we did you were a
different person right now but you're in
a different place I was definitely in a
different way yes yes things change as
time goes on things have changed time
heal and those wounds you flipped your
personal house right I have no I
definitely
I work hard each and every day yeah yeah
redid everything yeah you know a lot of
people talked about working hard in
business and I think it's we're in live
I think it's most important to work on
yourself so I think anyone who's out
there going through any struggles or
dealing with any issues I think it's
really important to take it take care of
yourself first so you can take care of
others well what did that mean for you
did it mean like physically working out
did it means there
how have you been working on yourself
you know it's a combination of many
different things you know therapy
working out and I was dealing with a
struggling because of my medications for
my cancer some of the side effects I
dealt with were causing anxiety
depression and all these different
things so there were a lot of things
involved to get me to the place that I'm
at today
okay so flip or flop new season do you
have a favorite episode one that you're
really stoked for the fans to see oh
yeah I do have a favorite episode it's
in Newport Beach it's about a twenty-two
twenty-three hundred square foot house
and I'm having a fun time with it
because it's a high-end home so I'm
doing custom everything custom cabinets
flooring wallpaper lighting vanities so
I get to take like all my favorite looks
and do custom work which I love doing
high-end custom work okay how do you
have time to take this lovely lady out
on a date does that do you both are you
both really busy is that what helps that
you understand each other's lives oh you
know what we would somehow we make it
happen bleed or not like I'm in LA
everyday now and I'm like I was on the
road I don't know what time it is I'm a
where I'm at but you know I'm having
like the best time ever so I wouldn't
change a thing for the world love it I'm
gonna ask you a big question at the end
here would you get married again that is
a big question yes I I think yeah you
know I think if two people love each
other that's what you do and I think
that that's just that's what you do in
life yeah alright I think that's a huge
commitment and that's telling someone
that they're yours forever mm-hmm so
yeah do you think you would have said
that a couple years ago oh no Jill we
just go okay certified I'm just kidding
she's honest oh no no IIIi all say you
know love will make you do crazy things
and I'm a huge believer in love and yeah
I think so
all right well tark thank you so much
thank you are you I'm this is I don't
know if I've ever witnessed this we have
a man who has renovated his entire life
just like you renovate houses I love
everything about that yeah why not well
I coming back is always better than a
setback and this is like my fifth come
back and we're here for all of it
[Music]